but white's pieces are are quite scary
as well oh wait one second isn't there
okay knight takes rook yeah i was
expecting the white rook
there's a big threat rook takes knight
oh look at the bar oh no is it a blunder
by prague look at him it's a big blunder
by prague unfortunately and he's just
missed that black can actually sacrifice
a queen on the next turn he thought that
the white knight could come and check
the black king but it doesn't work and
we'll have to show that in a moment but
prague first of all is heartbreak for
him big big blunder there he actually
had a very good move the white rook
could have just moved out of the attack
moved out of the threat and the game
goes on uh prague would have had decent
chances but magnus there he knows he's
winning now the white knight forced to
retreat to attack black's queen but
that's not what prague wanted head in
his hands he's just lost a rook for only
one piece
material advantage now decisive in
black's favor
and uh just while we keep an eye on
prague we have to show what just
happened
it was a huge mistake here the black
knight attacking the white